what do you think about the walrus
operator if you're familiar with it at
all
the reason it's interesting there's a
new operator in python 3.8
i find it psychologically interesting
because it the toxicity over it led
guido to resign
to step down from us being actually or
was it like there's a bunch of
surrounding things that also
was it actually the walrus operator that
well
it was it was a text it was an
accumulation of toxicity
but that was the the most that was the
most toxic one
like the discussion that's the most
number of python core developers that
were opposed to guido's decision
um he didn't particularly i don't think
cared about either way
he just thought it was a good idea this
is where you prove it
and like the structure of the idea of a
bdfl is like
you listen everybody hear everybody out
you make a decision and you move forward
and he didn't like the
negativity that burdened him after that
people like
some parts of the benevolent dictator
for life mantra but once the dictator
does things different than you want
suddenly dictatorship doesn't seem so
great
yeah i mean they still liked it he just
couldn't because he truly is
the bee in the benevolence he really is
a nice guy he
i mean and i think he can't it's a lot
of toxicity he's
difficult it's a difficult job that's
why elana's terrible is
perhaps the way he is you have to have a
thick skin to fight off
fight off the warring masses it's kind
of surprising to me how many people can
like
threaten to murder each other over
whether we should have braces or not or
whether
like it's incredible yeah i mean that's
my knee-jerk reaction to the walrus
operators like i don't actually care
that much either way i'm not going to
get gratefully passionate
my my initial reaction was like yeah
this seems to make things more confusing
to read
but then again so does list
comprehension until you're used to it
so like if there's a use for it great if
not great but like
let's just all calm down about our
spaces versus tabs debates here and like
be chill yeah to me just represents the
the value of great leadership even in
open source communities
does it represent that if he stepped
down as a leader well
he fought for it no he got it passed i i
guess but
i guess right it could represent
multiple things too it can represent
like
failed dictatorships or it could it
could represent a lot of things but to
me
great leaders take risks even if it
even if it's a mistake at the end like
you have to make decisions
the thing is this world won't go
anywhere if you
const if whenever there's a divisive
thing you
wait until the division is no longer
there like that's the paralysis we
experience with like congress and
political systems
it's good to be slow when there's
indecision uh when there's uh
people disagree it's good to take your
time but like at a certain point it
results in paralysis and you just have
to make a decision
the background of the site whether it's
yellow
blue or red can cause people to like go
to war over each other
i've seen this with design people are
very touched on color
color choices at the end of the day just
make a decision
and go with it i think that that's what
the walrus
operator represents to me is it
represents the fighter pilot instinct of
like quick action
is more important than uh than just like
carrying everybody out and really
thinking through it because that's going
to lead to
paralysis yeah like if that's the actual
case that you know
um it's something we're consciously
hearing people's uh disagreement
disagreeing with that disagreement and
saying he wants to move forward anyway
that's an admirable aspect of leadership
you